as a way in, i was so pissed when i was reading this last night i'm like oh my god this whole
fucking book has been an ad for it's like a promo for Being and Time when you get to the last three
lectures it's like oh it turns out that Being and Time are the answer and you're like really
i mean i'm joking obviously but yeah um but a real question a real question i have and this
has just been percolating in the back of my head it was doing this with Hegel when we did the
Phenomenology and it's doing this here and it does it somewhat with Derrida why the fuck are they just
do they not use the word becoming like they just don't yeah i know right like i mean because that
seems to me so clearly what each of these thinkers is after um now one would have to do work on the
concept of becoming because it can't simply be a secondary and derivative component of being
got it right like but we're doing work on being so why not right like you know like why do these why
do these folks what is what am i missing you know and i feel like i've got to be missing something i
mean was the word just not circulated like as a noun like is it just the terminology because there's
clearly a philosophy of movement here and he gets to that that central idea of becoming he just doesn't
actually use the term i don't even know what the German word would be am i right yeah well yeah i mean
like what height is that sort of you know that um the suffix that yeah right nominalize yeah like you
kind of do that work with the participle there so yeah i don't know if i don't know if just English
kind of affords that kind of language but my understanding is that at least Deleuze gets the
language of becoming from Bergson and then it doesn't really traffic before that and so you know
maybe the French language you know allows for right introduction of that i don't i but but like i mean
to response to your question John is that you know Hegel Derrida and Heidegger are all invested in
something yeah i would say definitely something called becoming but they arrive at it in very
different ways especially Hegel Heidegger and you know like lecture nine to me just like you know
if i were going to try to sum it up quickly is that uh Hegel was invested in the becoming of reason
the becoming like the movement of this sort of rationalized uh under the movement of understanding
right and Heidegger is more interested in a kind of becoming that happens in sort of
sort of well we'll talk about this but he's more interested in a kind of becoming that is prior
to the domination of the understanding and the reason and reason and again he's he's very clear
that you know he you know he doesn't think that this whole um rationalization thing is like a mistake
or you know somehow like no that's right you do get the language of like progress and like you
have to pass through that movement of rationalism or the enlightenment thinking there is that kind
of language of like development here and there which kind of seemed very Hegelian at least at
points right like the notion that well i got the opposite that that like that there's you know this
prior thinking is not a proto thinking that it's not a thinking that hasn't yet you know sort of
introduced reason to it is that right i mean i i really got the sense here is that the very act
that the Greeks had access to something something called thinking that they sort of like developed
this thinking and that it was in some ways destined to arrive at conceptual rational thinking but the
but that destiny that sort of that kind of progress or i don't know what's what they call it that kind
of development um in some fundamental ways covers over the engine that got it then that yeah it
obfuscates how it got there and then you know it that then it's like it's still available it's still
available in that thinking like one can reactivate it if one does the kind of thing that Heidegger is
doing so it's not like it's totally disappeared but i agree there's a sense of a you know like he
says you know the Greeks think non-conceptually right they don't have concepts um and i mean i kind
of there there's a way which at least for me you know we've talked so much about that sort of nostalgic
dimension in here and the attempt to get an end run i was a little bit more sympathetic in this context
for for whatever reason of like okay like there's a i just wish you wouldn't say something like the
Greeks i just don't like those cultural those big cultural claims like i think that you can say
there's a thinking in Aristotle um that doesn't think thinking or that thinks thinking as the
revealing and taking the the laying out and taking to heart i think one can say that um and and say
like okay in there's something available in Aristotle that's that's just not as available in Aquinas or
or whoever whoever else without making a big claim about the the Greeks thinking right though i find it
To be interesting that that Nietzsche Deleuze do very similar things with with the Greeks and you know
not in the very typical way of like the Greeks were the paragon of of you know of rational thinking and
that everything we have we've just inherited from them but more in terms of sort of like the singularity
of a historical moment is that human activity converged in such and such a way in this very sort of small
place in this you know particular time that enabled something and you know Deleuze I think is very
careful to say like look that stuff has in some ways its origins in Babylon in the in the sort of like
Fertile Crescent area in Egypt but you still but you wouldn't call you know sort of um uh that kind
of uh astrology or or mysticism philosophy because it doesn't converge in such and such a way something
something new is expressed in in a particular convergence in this moment and you know from
Heidegger's perspective it seems like and that convergence brought about another convergence that
covered over this one and yeah I I do think that that looking back though does tend to lend itself to
fetishizing but but again like you do need a point of departure so like in the reaction against uh the
modern technologizing of thought which Nietzsche Deleuze Heidegger all share a similar reaction to that
they all find a different mode of thinking in a similar place right in in that cultural moment in
that historical moment in the Greek so it doesn't have to be a fetishizing of the Greeks I just think
Heidegger here and there it does kind of lend itself to that kind of disposition but again like
in in these sections I found that there was a wavering on that point where he was admitting that
basically the modern epoch the modern image of thought is in some ways constitutive that while
it's different from the Greeks we are now we have to deal with the way that we relate and that mode
of relating now as a constitutive in in order to move past it or in order to transmute it right like
well he makes that claim with Nietzsche and Kierkegaard right like even though these you know we're all
caught up in this system and even you know the sort of like greatest you know antigens to systemic
thought like Kierkegaard and Nietzsche are still caught up caught up entangled in it right right but I
don't think he thinks he is like I think he thinks that of Kierkegaard and Nietzsche I agree
but I I think that he thinks that he has figured out how to activate the echoes of this proto not again it
wouldn't be proto but this other kind of this other kind of thinking within the ratio right like yeah
um and one of the well it couldn't be within the ratio though anymore right like I mean that's that's
what he's claiming that Nietzsche and Kierkegaard do but I don't know how he could be could claim that
he gets outside of it I want to anticipate something because I know it's happening and and you know
talking about anxiety events I've got to like get it out there before you know I kind of know when it
happens so uh John I know your response to this I already know your trajectory on this because you're
going to make a claim about how concepts for Heidegger are the bad guy and that concept sort of like still
a proper kind of thinking and we need to kind of undo them and you're going to point to Deleuze's
Difference and Repetition wherein concepts sort of like are the domesticators of difference but then
you're going to jump to uh philosophy and you're going to say wait a second a particular kind of
engagement with with with concepts can actually be a kind of thinking and you know and I and I and I
follow that but okay I just got to get that out on the table first just as I know that's what's gonna
happen it saves us time it saves us time I wasn't planning on doing that but I I certainly have done
that I don't know I don't care if you were planning on doing it or not it was going to happen yeah it
was inevitable it was inevitable but you know it is going to lead us to a you know like how do we take
up you know now that we are sort of embroiled in concepts and you know like I think Hegel is the
best thinker on this is that look there is a you know even within the sort of rigidify like like
reifying nature of the understanding to create and reproduce concepts there is a becoming within that
something like how does one engage how does one think concepts that that would be like a question
here is you know rather than distinguish ratio conceptual thinking from this sort of more active
thinking how does one activate or how does one become involved with or how does one as you know he
puts that how does one um not grasp concepts but uh you know to like uh let them lie before let yeah let
them lie before and take them up in one's heart to think the being of the the the the being of the
concept right yeah and I do think there is an investment in that later or I don't know when to lose
right what is philosophy but in that particular mode where he's not just saying the concepts are the bad
Guy he's saying that if you have a particular orientation towards conceptual thinking you can
allow concepts to play with each other and form linkages and do different types of things other
than that telos to grasp, right? So it's like, and I think Heidegger is saying here, at least in a couple
places, right, I'm on 227 towards the end, where he's talking about, um, dualisms or duality between
particular beings and capital capital B being. That's the whole that's the being of the time, right? Right,
exactly, he's saying logical that the duality of the two must be given beforehand in such a way that
this duality itself does not as such receive specific attention. So he's talking about that kind of
reified version of conceptuality of the modern time, where you don't, there's presuppositions that allow
you to have concepts grasp the real, right? And it's trying to think that movement and maybe getting
underneath or behind or before that movement, letting it lie before you is is sort of the aim here. That's
what allows concepts to play rather than simply to reify the world or experience. So that's exactly the
point. They actually, I think that I wasn't going to go the direction that Nathaniel uh thought, even
though I have done it many times, but but because because I am interested in this this duality thing,
and I really because no one uses becoming, and I don't want to see that as simply a error or a missed
something missed. I'm like, I kind of wanted to immerse myself more in the being question here, like and
just sort of think through being and that where where you just pointed to Nate and the continuation of
that in the next page is like that was a place where I really uh that that I thought was really
important. Yeah, that the presumption that the distinction the duality between the two being
and beings um must be given beforehand in such a way that this duality itself does not as such
receive specific attention. So we're just the dis the distinction of beings of being big B being and
the ontocontological distinction is kind of given and then he said the same is true for all transcendence.
When we pass from beings to being our passage passes through the duality of the two and this is the
thing that sounds incredibly not Heideggerian to me this next sentence but the passage never first
creates the duality. I would think the passage would be exactly what creates the duality, right? Right,
right, like the in other words, the movement of you know forging is so like because in my version there
would be this performative movement that induces retrospectively the notion that there was a duality
beforehand. But he said the duality the duality is already in use it is the thing most used and thus
most usual in all our stating and ideas and all we do and and so i i feel like and this is a real
question that i have because i sometimes feel as if my response or i was going to say solution in
quotation marks but my solution to this problem is if you just give up the idea that thinking is
representation, like if you just say that's just wrong, like inaccurate or however you want to
understand wrong, and you think of it performatively, all of this problem goes away, right? It's just all of
it. And i'm like, what what am i missing in saying that, like, because it just seems like such an easy
solution, where you say not that the passage never first you say like no the passage is what creates
the duality between big B being and little b beings and what you get then is the movement of
thinking in the sense of letting it lie before you and taking to heart the dual component of that
is what produces the distinction and the reason i the only reason i can come up with that he doesn't
want to say that is because that then says that the greeks created the technological culture, right?
That's where it leads. In other words, it's not it wasn't a there's not like a kernel to be reactivated
where we could somehow get back. It's like no no no the reactivation is going to produce more
technological or representational, right? Because in other words you get into way more of a vicious
circle if if you say the thing that i thought hiding i mean my god the passage doesn't create the
distinction like that's all he ever says is the passage is the thing that creates the distinction.
He does make that claim that that Greek thinking and that sort of originary authentic essential sense
is the sort of like precursor for techno rational thinking. I mean, you know, this is on 213 and that
that second paragraph right after he's like, you know, Kierkegaard and Nietzsche you know we're sort of
caught up in this um the systemization this which is effectively like you know medieval scholasticism but
that next paragraph but we must give attention to another matter the interpretation of Greek thinking that
guided by modern conceptual thinking not only remains inappropriate for Greek thinking it also keeps us from
hearing the appeal of the problematic of Greek thinking and thus from being held to a constantly
more urgent summons to go on questioning we must not fail, of course, to reflect on why in a wet way it is
precisely the thinking of the Greeks that essentially prepared the development of uh thinking in the sense of
forming conceptual ideas. Indeed, Greek thinking was bound to suggest that development uh, and and keep on going
here, but on the path which we are following here, the important thing for us is to first see that our
modern way of representational ideas, as long as it stubbornly holds it this way, blocks its own access to
the beginnings and thus the fundamental characteristic of Western thinking. The translations alone make the point
clear. I mean, it seems like this is like just to jump in there, just how non-Nietzschean that is, right? Like, I mean
and and to me that's everything is this distinction right here, which is it for him uh, the the translation
that's gone from the Greek mode of thinking to those blocks our access to the previous one, whereas for
Nietzsche it's just another articulation. It's just another like an interpretation. It's just folding
it from this point to this point and then you fold it from another point to another point, like yeah no
but there's a historical claim that I follow there. I mean, like think about well so that basically you
know the the full development of this sort of Greek way of thinking uh makes the very thing like in in
its expression in ratio sort of representational thinking bars the way from the thing that genesis
did, right? I mean in the same way that like you know in uh Nietzsche's version of of uh um interpretation
you know sort of like that physiological notion of interpretation is you know they're taking hold
of say like the ear, the eye, or the nose by the human organism, like in like like how are we supposed to
know, you know, what set of relationships that thing was caught up in beforehand? You'd have to run some
kind of like weird genealogical. The huge difference, and this is the key difference, is that for Heidegger
that origin remains fundamental. For Nietzsche it's just another moment. Yeah, right. So like so I i get where
Nietzschean interpretation you could say blocks access because the thing is something else, but it's not
who needs the access? Like you don't need to get to the access, whereas for Heidegger you do, right? Like
there is something that is sort of lost or covered over or not as available or not laying in plain view
or something because of the ratio or subsequent interpretations of the laying before and taking
to heart. I mean, but so like like take sorry but sorry yeah just the the general existence of the
genealogy of of morals, right, would be sort of like you know all of these utilitarians, all of these sort
of like progressive evolutionary thinkers like have gotten this wrong to sort of assume that there's
some kind of telos here, that everything is progressing toward, and i'm going to do a genealogy
that shows the weird twisty turny ways in which you know this this history of appropriations, this
history of uh interpretations, has has sort of set up and you know like i would say for Nietzsche
there is a style of Greek thinking, a style of Greek living that is in some ways inaccessible to us
now. Like i understand he doesn't say and we should go back and live there, you know? Like his response is
you know we you know there's um uh we should invent maybe invent with it, right, rather than recover or
re-access uh it, but there does like the very function of a genealogy does seem to like be aimed at some
kind of of of kind of like a historical recovery project does it not? But i don't agree so so that's
where to me like what's the solution to birth of tragedy? It's not like we need to get back to
the Dionysian Socrates. Yeah, right? Like we need to so that right so I mean that's a huge difference, like
it's not a recovery project in right exactly right. It's like okay let's let's push this even further
like let's you know here here is the trajectory in the line let's let's push it further as opposed to
you know our way is blocked and we get back and reactivate it and we will find i mean that's that
sense again nostalgia or whatever i mean it's it there is to me i just read a very i i take your
point and i think that that point about the the architecture of the genealogy, there's a way in
which he is sort of saying like look these basic sort of affirmative you know uh uh resentful dynamics
are like these are the origins that set everything else in motion, right? So everything that you think is
like Christian niceness is resentment, right? Like um, and that's that's the engine of the thing but the
goal is not then to like well let's recover the truly affirmative way from some prior version. It is
like let's now affirm it, right? Like what is it? Yeah, what does it mean to now affirm means like to take
the thing as it is and to re-articulate, to reinterpret, to hook it to something else and make it do something
else. But the claim the claim functions similarly though, like even if it's not an historical recovery
project in Nietzsche there is still a blockade or like there's a blockage in our thinking that disallows
certain modes of relating and like think about the revenge against difference or even the in truth and
lies how conceptuality masks or kind of covers over an irreducible difference that um is kind of outside the the
the movement of subjectivity or conceptuality right it's like but but for Nietzsche and for Heidegger
here the interesting thing for me is that the blockade is not simply something you can do away
with right this is a constitutive blockade in some ways that yeah in that almost in a Hegelian sense
you have to pass through in order to get to the overman or in order to get to you know whatever
Heidegger's poetic mode of engagement right like this you have to take the blockade seriously
i think i just don't think it's a blockade in Nietzsche like i i don't think it's a blockade
it's just a development it's a change change it's not like right but it's a problem it's well i would
say it is a blockade but not a problem for Nietzsche in that like if you don't need to go around it or
through or back to or reaccess something then the blockage isn't a problem but it's still a blockage
in other words like you know there's transformation is never like a smooth line where you can move
back and forth it's like you know the the very um uh mechanism of becoming the very mechanism of the
of futurity or the overman is to obscure it's it's like and to blockade its its origin points now for
Heidegger that seems to be a problem for Nietzsche that doesn't seem to be a problem uh like you know
know Nietzsche is more interested in like saying like you know look at this history of of appropriations
and i'll call it a genealogy never want to go back to one of them but now look Heidegger
Heidegger is at a different historical moment i can see why it would be more appealing to say like
shit you know like this essential ambiguity like the which for me i i just you know it just became
increasingly clear to me that essence is futurity here is potentiality here and he doesn't like i
don't think he wants to go back to the Greeks to stay there it just feels like he's like we took the
wrong fucking turn man like if this is you know if this was sort of like an intersection we took a
left and we should have taken a right or frankly any other direction that isn't this direction because
affirming this ratio instrumentalization thing that's you know i mean holocaust right climate
destruction you know like the reduction like the hyper reduction of all thinking like i'll take any
other direction just not this one this one's fucked and given where Heidegger is coming from i understand
that impulse now i think if you're going to take up a Nietzschean or Deleusian writing like there's no going
back and the only chance you have to sort of mitigate or you know deal with these you know i don't like i
don't think Deleuze or Nietzsche like the holocaust or fascism any any more than Heidegger does but like
you can't go back you only can affirm and invent so as to transmute and let me try a different angle
into it i mean and i really am i guess bent on distinguishing what the Nietzschean genealogical
project and and not in the interest of thinking that Nietzsche is a cool guy but because i just read
something different going on there that for instance
even though Nietzsche obviously talks you know the origin of good and whatever he just doesn't
have any interest in origins he doesn't have any interest like so for instance his origin thing is just
another interpretation right and he he foregrounds it's like so i can talk about the Greeks but i might i
could be talking about somebody like it doesn't matter like the Greeks are just a place they are
not the thing that started western thinking down a trajectory you know it's just this is just a place
uh and there are other places that have different dynamics to them but there's nothing special about
the origin moment that makes it the fundamental character of western thinking or i mean think of
the other the other things that follow from this right like the problematic obviously the famous
sentence in here right where like India and Africa what is it India and China have a philosophy
right well that's not that's not the claim is that uh India and Chinese philosophy i mean he definitely
it's not philosophy no he said well it's it's the same it's the same it's conceptual philosophy it's
the same kind of philosophy you get in the west
no it's not where's let's find the passage there is okay on one 224 the style of all western
European philosophy and there is no other neither a Chinese nor an Indian philosophy is determined
by this duality beings in being philosophy okay nevermind i read this right like uh i read that as
saying that the the problem the problem of western philosophy is the problem of all philosophy
but yeah no i just misread that well there's no Chinese and Indian philosophy right like it's and
And for the reasons I get the historical reasons he wants to think that, but that's where the Greeks
set us on a path for Heidegger for nature. The Greeks were just a moment, right? Like, uh,
and not a moment in the the evolution of spirit, just a moment like and there's something interesting
that one can now interpret and activate in them, but not because something was lost by you know, in the
in the two thousand years between them, just because it's available there; it's available elsewhere
right? Like, it's it's available in Napoleon, it's available in, you know, for for Nietzsche, right? It's
available in Wagner's music, but again, like, you know, Deleuze is really careful to say that
like, you know, in a sense there is no non-Greek philosophy even for Deleuze. Yeah, no, I agree, I
i agree, but the sense of it is really really different in to me here and in and Deleuze's like why?
Yeah, I mean the geo philosophy they're like why here, right? Like why here and then why this time
why not, right, which is to say, which isn't I mean I think there there is a connotation here that you
know philosophy is better and therefore anything that doesn't have philosophy you know like is is
worse off and i but you know that i don't i don't i don't think that's what to lose is going on with
the lose i'm not even sure that it's what is going on here. I don't think that's what's I don't think I
i don't think it's a better or worse thing. I think it's the claim of the duality between being and
beings, right? That's a fundamental, right? But but but in inaugurating performing that particular uh
duality does set something on a path. Now it's not a predetermined path that can only go one
direction, you know, like but it does set a direction and it does kind of like pre-shape the available
turns, you know, like, you know, it's like, you know, every time you take a step forward from that duality
it's like you got six different choices but not a million, right? Yeah, but I mean it's it's at least
to me it just feels like I I don't think he's privileging this here as sort of better. He's saying
what counts as philosophy begins from an unrecognized distinction between beings and being
right? Like that's where it begins, and so there's lots of other things that we could loosely
call thinking and we could call you know attentiveness or whatever, but they're not
philosophy, and they're not philosophy because they don't begin with that unrecognized problematic; it's
not like Parmenides said hey I'm going to pursue the question like Parmenides is the one who raised
and didn't answer, right? Or or didn't sort of spend time with, like right above that the the Chinese
Indian quote it's like, you know, he just quotes Parmenides saying take the heart, the eon is
participle and with it take he to the acai and eon the being of beings however no further inquiry
and thought is given to the duality itself of being and beings neither to the nature of the duality to
that nor to that nature's origin. So the Greeks both raise it and and don't address it, right? Um, and
that has determined, you know, that distinction is determined, but that is Being and Time, right? That is
the thing that he like how do you ask the how do you even ask the ontological question beings and
and big B being, right? Like how do you pose that? And so that's where I I really do think he sees himself
in the same way that Hegel does, right? He sees himself as the completion of a lineage and that
to me is a huge tonal difference between Nietzsche does not see that, right? Like he doesn't see himself
as completing a lineage. He seems himself as offering a direction that's different than others. You would
have to see him being incredibly facetious then in this sort of like all of the ways that he amplifies
the importance of ambiguity and potentiality and you know like the main maintenance of the questioning
like, you know, he couldn't see himself uh like he couldn't be Heidegger and see himself as the
completion of anything because here's what I would say here's what I would say on the ambiguity question like
that's gone from this conversation. It's gone, right? He doesn't talk about ambiguity in relation to being
at all, right? The being stuff was all in the what we would now call the ontic realm, right? Um, it wasn't
in that sort of baseline question of the ontic ontological; that's that's not uh that dualism isn't
something that would be I don't think he would call it ambiguous. It is constitutive and fundamental
no I would say it's constitutively ambiguous the being big you know beings the ontic uh on yeah the
ontic ontos uh yeah big B being little b beings like no that is that dynamic is a constitutive
ambiguity, right? I mean like I think ambiguous because ambiguous I mean the like the necessity of here's what I
agree with the necessity of thinking them together can't work in an instrument it can't provide an
answer like I agree with that, right? Except for here is the answer one must try to think these together
You know what I mean. So it's still it's not it's like here is the problem, like the the problem is this
the problem is Being in Time, right? Like that one must think these, think the being and beings uh somehow
together. I mean, I I'm using ambiguous, like he talked a lot about ambiguity earlier, but it was never in
relation to being, you know, I mean, that that that terminology just falls out when we get to it was
in relation to thinking, right? Ambiguity, the ambiguous essence of thinking. And I think yeah, you could extend
that and say that the duality between capital B being and beings or singularities, the effect of that
duality is some sort of ambiguity and the tendency of conceptual thinking is to elide that ambiguity
right, so the the that as a presupposition, the duality itself as a fundamental presupposition or
assumption of modern thinking that actually in some ways engenders the ambiguity as its effect
right because of all of the assumptions that are loaded into it and the way it allows us to advance our
thinking right in quotes, like the whole movement of thinking because it stems from the dualism or the
opposition. And again this is a Hegelian sort of point. Yeah, yeah, because the the opposition is in a
sense primary as a as a function of modern thinking. That's what the ambiguity follows from that, right? And the
the ambiguity actually is a part of the masking of itself. Does that make any sense? I I I got a bit
lost. No that makes sense, that makes sense yeah. But but what I I took at least from the first half of
what you were saying is that there why does he make such a big deal about being a sort of being a vacuous
term, you know? Is because you know it has been so instrumentalized in our in our language and our
conceptual fabric for engaging the world. Is that like being has no real meaning? It's so self-present
so self-obvious to us that things are to the point where you know attaching the word are or is or whatever
else seems you know superfluous and you know it seems to me that the the return to the uh um
ontic ontos dynamic is for the sake of undermining that obviousness and reactivating a certain kind of
primary ambiguity that there needs to be like that relationship is uh becomes you know rationalized
when it becomes determined but it must always maintain attention and this is where I was waiting
for him to use the language of becoming and this is the closest he gets to the language of becoming
is that you know like in some ways independent of thinking being and uh being being that that
that fundamental ambiguity is is operative. That is the food for thought. Now like something else happens
when thinking engages it becomes involved with it when it's a lie before and taken up to heart but like
that sort of activation of the world around us as that kind of tension can only exist when it becomes
when it is taken up as fundamentally constitutively ambiguous and I think he gets at this
at the best uh in in lecture 10 where he starts engaging for the first time you know that that
participle the the the participle of the present participle of being, so the very bottom of 219 and
then the top of 220 when he starts thinking about the relationship between blossoming gleaming
resting. I mean if you don't mind, you know, so I'll just read that section. This is the bottom of 219.
A grammatical reflect a reflection is needed to make the point clear. What reservations there are
concerning the extent of its validity will become obvious and what follows the word being by its
structure sounds and speaks like the terms blossoming gleaming resting aching and so on. The grammatical
name of long-standing words so formed is participle they participate they take part in two meanings but the
but the essential point is not that there are only two meanings instead of three or four but that the
two meanings refer to each other. Each of the two meanings is one of the pair. The word blossoming can
mean given uh the given something that is blossoming, the rose bush or the apple tree
uh if the word is intended in the sense it designates uh what stands in bloom
the noun that's the noun yeah that's the noun um but it can also be the act of blossom right designates
the given something uh that is blossoming and intends this something by itself as that which uh
blossoming is fitting and proper. The word blossoming if it means for instance the rose
here has almost represents the proper name for what is uh designate in this linguistic form. It has the
character of the substance of a noun blossoming and so under so the noun but blossoming may also mean
the act of blossoming in contrast with the act of wilting uh what is meant is not the given plant
that happens to be blossoming or wilting but blossoming wilting here blossoming is used in the verbal
sense and this is almost actually just rereading that right there almost gives me a better
understanding of why he doesn't use the language of becoming because it would cling too heavily into
that second verbal notion of of of of blossoming where it is only the transformation of the thing
but it doesn't speak at all to kind of like a version of like a duration of the being of the being either
so it's both the becoming of the being and the being of the being it's both self-transformation
and and self-instantiation it's both uh the molecular and the molar at the same time
right and if you look at i mean like actually that the language of the molecular and the molar
sort of operative uh in fundamental uh attention ambiguity there like that assuages my like the you know
my concerns for the way that he uses being there that they can't like it is it is pure um potential i mean
it is pure potentiality right not and without tîa without tilia without a telos and thinking the
the simultaneity of becoming in our words and being right that that simultaneity is key and we've talked
about that in several episodes um how thinking basically like because John you raised earlier like
that part where he talks about the passage not coming before the duality right and now that's kind
of an odd conceptual uh intonation there because you would think at least in in terms of his uh you
know the people that come after him Derrida etc right difference would seem to be if we're going to use
slightly different terminology difference would seem to be primary to and constitutive of identity
or representation but i think even for for Derrida right there's you can reverse the copula and it's
just it's almost equally important to do that where identity also is primary to and constitutive of
difference so neither one of those can stand on their own and i think that might be one of Heidegger's
points here right is that you have to think that that simultaneity or that that kind of recursiveness
within the process right being becoming right they're constantly folding on top of one another
now the one target that i that you know i've been following what Nate said is that you know i think
usually critiques that come in the form of some kind of like becoming package are aimed at substantial
notions of being right like being as underlying substratum underlying substance underlying sort of like
self self self-presence right and within that lineage you know the language of becoming i think
makes a whole lot more sense but the passage by which Heidegger is taking here just sort of like
shoots down that substantial notion of being i think from the get-go and that there is something
far less determinant about being from the beginning that you know that critique of becoming doesn't even
need to be doesn't even need to be introduced
let me just rewind for a second because this this passage was confusing to me because i don't
understand the first sense like in the simplest way i don't understand the noun version like i don't
think that you ever use blossoming gleaming and resting to refer to something that is blossoming gleaming
and resting right like yeah i thought that was a little odd like they don't function on their own as
a noun really right i mean i get you've nominalized a verb right i get blossoming is a noun right i
understand that but but it's a noun that refers to an action which is the action of blossoming it doesn't
refer to so he says blossoming designates the given something that is blossoming i'm like
where you don't ever you say the flower is blossoming you don't right say you could say the tree is
blossoming look at that blossoming that's right you know that's fine blossoming in that case doesn't
refer to the tree like why do you have to have the word tree is because blossoming doesn't refer to the
thing like i don't i just like at that point i just didn't get the distinction that he's making
like in its linguistic form it has the character of a substantive noun like i i mean it does it has this
character of a substantive noun referring to an action and if that's the point he wants to make i
get that but what it doesn't do is if the word is intended in this sense it designates what stands
in bloom no it doesn't right it doesn't designate what that makes sense to me like it i mean to talk
about the blossoming tree like it would be all too sort of like surgical to say no it's only the flowers
that are blossoming because then you're like well you know like it's spring every like tree on this
street is blossoming and so like when i say the blossoming tree do i mean this tree or that tree it's
like no like blossoming is now like a substantial uh uh like attribute of this of the tree like there
right yeah of the tree but of the tree the tree is the substantive right but but the but the tree has
been constituted like uh or is constituted by the blossoming and if it's constituted it can constitute
if it's constituted by the blossoming then the being of the tree has taken up blossoming as part of
its being does that make sense in the sentence the tree is blossoming i i still i mean i i get
yeah I get that, I get that, that's that's a little closer and helpful to me because I just think of
the tree is blossoming. Blossoming there doesn't refer to the tree, it refers to the action of
blossoming, that is an attribute of the tree I think, but I think those are the two pathways, so
just think about this is actually really fun because I think like we're actually doing the thinking of
being, right? Like in that sense the tree is blossoming, we're thinking the is right there, like
and right right I think there are two senses of using that word is, like one is the is of the verb
right, which is the tree is doing the action of, that's something that it's doing, that's something
that is this is what the thing is is, you know, exactly like as a blossoming e that is becomes the equal
side right, like tree equals blossoming, right? But I get it, that helps, that that helps, I can understand
especially when you when we add in the is especially it helps me to distinguish like what the tree is is
is a blossoming, yeah, right, versus what the tree is doing is blossoming I was taking it entirely in
that second sense so because your ratio technical language has only allowed you to see it in terms
of subject object, right? And you had to reactivate that other sense of the being of is so I mean but
contrast this then with Nietzsche this is the lightning strikes yeah right like um whereas Nietzsche's claim
is different there which is the substantive is a bullshit occasion for the verb, right? Like the verb is
everything for him and the sub the substance is just a sort of residual who gives a fuck, you know, um so so
i think that you're right, like what Heidegger is attempting to do is to give emphasis to both hinges
um and what Nietzsche wants to do and I think what I want to do is to say that first hinge doesn't
fucking matter, it's just a residual it's it's the it's the evil in good and evil, right? It's the residual
after effect of an action I mean maybe you could think of it like the the reason the nominal needs
to be kept as also partly constitutive of the verbal the reason the verbal is not giving primary
ontological status here you could think of it like from the the like even cellular biology right like
what what's the autopoiesis or whatever yeah where you you need at least at a base level
something that functions like an identity in order to differentiate so at least at a provisional um
level ontologically or whatever even just ontically uh you you kind of need the nominal
at least in that provisional sense in order for there to be the verbal and vice versa in order for the
blossoming to take the tree the tree needs to be taken as object right or like to put this in terms
of active reactive force active force couldn't exist without reactive force because active force has
has to exert its force on something else forcing it into that nominal position right I mean this is why
i've become so increasingly interested in the molecular side or the molar side of the molar molecular
because the realization that you know that nominal substantial notion is bullshit is only the
first step and then the second one is to say all right it's a specter it's a ghost it's a residual
after effect it's whatever else and it still does something yeah no I I I'm totally down with the doing
so I just feel like I feel like if you go that way you inevitably go down Hegel Hegel's road right
like I mean inevitably yeah and you're saying there are basically two distinct forces identity and
indifference right or sameness and you know whatever whatever terms you want to pick and they're in
constant sort of war with one another and I feel like and that's the Hegel trajectory I feel like
there's another trajectory which is there is only active force and because of because of that there is
only reactive force for consciousness right like um and so there's one right that's it's the sort of
monistic thing that's primary or fundamental in that sense but it's not a thing right so you don't need
an identity in order to establish a difference you just have pure movement all of the time whose
residual effects are nominalizations and I'm not dismissing the residual effects and I'm not even
dismissing the importance of those residual effects but they're still secondary and derivative
you